Tất cả nhiều khi bị quá là quán và tất cả quyền mất những niệm chưa được trong quả khứ
và chính bản thân mình cần phải dựa đội.
Nếu không thì những vòng nọc như yêu sai chia tay thì sẽ dài mại.
Và phải tất sức tính tạo để nhận tàn những sai nở.
Khắc có ký tâm những lỗi sai không được lập lại với người mới thì đó mở sự chậm phải ký dơ thể.
Tại vì yêu rất là nhiều người bản thân thành thì cũng người xả nọc của chắc trung trình yêu.
Mình không có tâm những nhận là mình sai.
Tức ra những lỗi sai như yêu nó không phải là cái việc là game sai,
thì cũng đúng đẩy game như thế sai mà nó chảy.
Tức nguy em mũa mũa mũa mũa mũa, nó mũa không bú sức quan tâm những người ta, nó tạm ná mình không bú sức chết.